i
[Música]
el mundo superó el millón de muertos por
cuenta de la pandemia de jove 19 y los
casos detectados se sitúan en más de 33
millones en europa ya varios países se
encuentran inmersos en una nueva ola de
contagios e imponen nuevas e impopulares
medidas para frenar su avance mientras
tanto en américa avanzan los des
confinamientos
tras conocerse información revelada por
el 'new york times' sobre las
declaraciones de impuestos del
presidente estadounidense donald trump
la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes nancy pelosi consideró
que la situación fiscal del mandatario
supone un problema de seguridad nacional
el republicano asegura tener pocas
deudas y haber pagado millones de
dólares al fisco la polémica divide a la
sociedad estadounidense de cara al
primer debate en 3 trump y byte en
se intensifican los combates en la
región de nagorno karabaj en disputa
entre armenia y azerbaiyán nuevos
intercambios de ataques dejaron decenas
de muertos y crece el temor de una
escalada del conflicto rusia urgió a las
partes a detener las acciones militares
mientras que turquía pidió a armenia
retirarse en lo que califica como
tierras ocupadas en azerbaiyán
muy buenas noches gracias por continuar
con nosotros en france 24 y revelan que
un gusto saludarlos comenzamos a este
informativo con información de la
pandemia de kobe 19 pues el mundo superó
el millón de muertos según el conteo
oficial de la universidad johns hopkins
los casos confirmados ya superan los 33
millones y son casi 23 millones los
recuperados la organización mundial de
la salud aseguró este lunes que la cifra
real de muertes podría ser mayor a la
registrada el continente americano está
al frente con 16.3 millones de casos e
indé superó el umbral de los 6 millones
y es que el aumento de los contagios
genera particular preocupación en europa
ya que la región se acerca la temporada
internal varios países se han visto
obligados a implementar nuevas e
impopulares medidas para intentar frenar
la tasa de contagios informe de álvaro
cordero
los camareros franceses comienzan a
estar hartos por las medidas impuestas
ante el rebrote de coronavirus en
marsella los propietarios pusieron su
grito en el cielo ante un cierre
decretado de 15 días debido al aumento
de casos en el área metropolitana de la
segunda ciudad más grande de francia
no veo por qué nos ordenan cerrar a
pesar de los estrictos protocolos de
salud que hemos estado siguiendo si tú
reglamento es botón y siempre es la
misma historia tenemos las mascarillas y
el gel espera estuvo protestas que se
replican en parís donde los restaurantes
se verán obligados a cerrar a las 10 de
la noche mientras tanto en reino unido
las restricciones también se ampliaron
al noreste del país que registra tasas
de 100 contagios por cada 100.000
habitantes en ciudades como newcastle y
sunderland se prohibirá desde este
miércoles reunirse con personas de fuera
del hogar aunque el país que más
preocupa en europa es españa ya que ha
registrado más de 32.000 casos desde el
viernes el ministro de sanidad ha
advertido que las medidas se deben tomar
cuanto antes cuanto más tardemos más
duras y dadas medidas que tengamos que
aplicar y esto
verifique no hay quién
hay que ser muy claro conocido en judo
perdiendo al menos la situación es
complicada no basta con estabilizar hay
que doblarla por donde hay que doblar
hay que bajar esta incidencia acumulada
hay que hacerla descender y esto no es
fácil esto va a costar semanas va a ser
un esfuerzo de tenacidad en españa las
competencias en salud las tienen las
regiones y durante los últimos días la
polémica ha saltado entre la región de
madrid y el gobierno central ya que la
capital no se ha cerrado tal y como
sugirió el ministerio y se ha acusado a
la presidenta madrileña de confinar
solamente a los distritos más humildes y
mientras europa comienza a imponer
restricciones en américa latina' las
levantan en santiago chile 8 comunas que
estaban en confinamiento retomaron
actividades económicas esto supone que
toda la población de la ciudad del 97%
del área metropolitana puede circular
libremente por primera vez desde finales
de marzo el país supera los 450.000
casos de contagio y las 12 mil 600
muertes
ya se deseaba porque ya era mucho
encierro ya estábamos colapsando la
gente necesita trabajar pero creo que no
están dadas las condiciones todavía
porque si tú me pregunta si en el puente
a su primo cuarentena nunca la hubo y la
presidenta de la cámara de
representantes de eeuu nancy pelosi
aseguró que la situación fiscal de
donald trump es un asunto de seguridad
nacional afirmó que la ciudadanía tiene
el derecho a saber a quién donald trump
le debe dinero las revelaciones del 'new
york times' sobre las declaraciones de
impuestos el presidente son el principal
tema de debate en el país se crean una
nueva brecha en la polarización política
de cara a las elecciones louis van de
zúrich no tiene los detalles
frente a su propia torre portando un
traje de preso y leyendo en el 'new york
times' la investigación sobre sus
impuestos este falso donald trump la
muestra del principal tema que ronda la
mente de los estadounidenses este lunes
1 que promete profundizar aún más la
polarización política entre partidarios
y detractores del presidente de cara a
las elecciones
y todos sabíamos que esto iba a suceder
debido a que tratado de ocultarlo
durante mucho tiempo creo que ahora es
una prueba de que siempre ha pensado que
está por encima de la ley
mientras sobre cuánto dinero tiene y
cómo gana su dinero y este no es el tipo
de persona que debería estar liderando
al pueblo estadounidense
creo que es una coincidencia que dos
días antes del debate de new york times'
con fuentes anónimas y sin pruebas
presenté una historia así para tratar de
sesgar el debate esto
trump calificó la publicación como una
noticia falsa y ofreció su versión de
los hechos asegurando que ha pagado
millones de dólares al fisco la
demócrata nancy pelosi presidenta de la
cámara de representantes- expresó su
preocupación por las millonarias deudas
presuntamente contraídas por el
mandatario
hacemos un juramento de proteger y
defender el público tiene derecho a
saber a quién le debe el presidente
cientos de millones de dólares es una
cuestión de seguridad nacional
trump aseguró en un debate contra
hillary clinton en 2016 que no revela
sus declaraciones porque está bajo
auditoría cuatro años más tarde podría
repetir el mismo argumento en su primer
cara a cara contra joe biden previsto
para mañana
los combates entre las fuerzas a series
y armenias por el control del enclave
separatista a nagorno karabaj se
recrudecieron este lunes pese a los
múltiples llamados internacionales para
un cese al fuego los combates que
dejaron por lo menos 55 muertos ponen en
entredicho la estabilidad del cáucaso
sur una región por donde pasó
importantes gasoductos y también
oleoductos se teme que una escalada del
conflicto pueda terminar implicando a
grandes potencias como rusia y turquía
azerbaiyán y armenia declararon la ley
marcial lago roja la baja es una región
en disputa desde la caída de la unión
soviética y para analizar lo que ocurre
en esta región del mundo quiero saludar
en este momento a alfonso soria ex
embajador de colombia en egipto
especialista del magreb y docente de la
universidad externado de colombia
profesor buenas noches gracias por estar
aquí con nosotros en france 24 le
pregunto a las implicaciones que tiene
este conflicto en la región del cáucaso
y si estábamos ante la posibilidad de
una escalada mayor de estos
enfrentamientos posiblemente con
intervención de grandes potencias
buenas noches es importante establecer
algo que este conflicto viene desde 1991
cuando se declaró en agosto 30 agosto la
independencia esta mañana entonces el 12
de septiembre en ese año
en seguida el pse clero la a la
independencia
del separatismo de nagorno karabaj por
parte de la mayoría armenia esto ha
llegado a alguna evolución de 1994 el
grupo de minsk conformado por la sc
rusia estados unidos y francia
colaboraron en una una propuesta de paz
y una mediación y hoy en día las
condiciones son distintas desde 1994
vemos que el mundo ha cambiado desde
este momento hay una gran
en potencias regionales que quieren un
mayor protagonismo y es rusia la pulsera
putin y la turquía de erdogán nosotros
pensamos históricamente son dos antiguos
imperios que que quieren tener su
protagonismo y esta es la zona el radio
de acción de ellos en ms m
en estos momentos así es profesor
entonces viendo todo lo que está
ocurriendo en este momento se puede
decir que los años de esfuerzo de la
comunidad internacional para lograr la
paz en esta región han fracasado le
pregunto si hay alguna manera de poder
lograr la estabilidad y la paz en esta
región
el tema que yo no diría fracasado el
problema que estaba en una
transformación de todos los principales
actores en la comunidad internacional
primero que todo hay una gran paréntesis
en el multilateralismo y hoy en día
nosotros vemos que a pesar de los 75
años de las acciones unidas hay poco
manejo que pueda hacer naciones unidad
desde ahí tenemos que ver que esa dupla
turquía rusia también se presenta un
poco en la región como los analistas
internacionales han dicho que es un tema
de poderío militar de ser una disuasión
militar pero igualmente tiene una
cogestión diplomática en los casos de
siria en los casos de libia y ahora nos
encontramos en el conflicto de nagorno
karabaj tenemos también una un eeuu
color de una política interna bien
compleja en los temas de reelección del
presidente todo y tenemos de pronto una
europa debilitada por los temas de
crimea de la acción por función de
crimea y un tema hoy en día
del arroz que nos
vemos que a pesar de los esfuerzos y la
visita que tiene previsto es eficiente
macrón en la región está un poco o
impide nosotros podemos pensar que clic
es una ayuda de carácter diplomático que
un poco para hoy en día profesor gracias
por estar con nosotros que tengo usted
una muy buena noche la inhabilitación
por desobediencia del presidente
regional de cataluña al independentista
quinto ra confirmada este lunes por el
tribunal supremo español abre la
posibilidad de nuevas elecciones en esa
comunidad autónoma nuestra corresponsal
el issga schenkel con los detalles para
su destitución del presidente catalán
quinto acá dio un último discurso aquí
en este palacio de la generalitat en el
que dijo por lo que el único camino
hacia la independencia era la ruptura
democrática y también pidió que las
próximas elecciones catalanas derivadas
de su inhabilitación fueran un
plebiscito a la independencia de
cataluña mientras aquí se congregaron
centenares de manifestantes pese a las
y visiones de vidas alcohol 19 los
manifestantes se le pedían al presidente
desobedecer esta sentencia cosa que no
hizo al final la acepto pues resignado y
bajó a esta misma plaza con la los
manifestantes exhibiendo una pancarta la
misma pancarta que tenía colgada aquí en
esta falsedad de la generalidad durante
la última campaña electoral y que él
provocó que el fuego destituido por el
tribunal supremo hoy después él se dio
un último baño de masas antes de irse en
su coche oficial y algo a su vez el
presidente pega agones y tendrá que ser
el nuevo presidente en funciones
este lunes se conmemora el día
internacional por la legalización del
aborto un derecho fundamental que está
gravemente maltratado en américa latina'
la región tiene algunas de las leyes más
punitivas en cuanto a los derechos
reproductivos de las mujeres en la
estabilidad política la religión y la
desigualdad son algunas de las
principales causas que impiden la
despenalización de la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo una situación
que se ha grabado con la pandemia
marinas ardilla nos amplía
es urgente es prioridad es el lema en
américa latina' en el día internacional
por la legalización del aborto
la conmemoración creada en 1990 busca
intensificar la lucha por despenalizar
el acceso al aborto legal y seguro un
derecho fundamental para las mujeres el
97% de las mujeres latinoamericanas en
edad fértil viven en países donde el
aborto está prohibido como el salvador
honduras nicaragua o haití la región se
caracteriza por contar con legislaciones
restrictivas y políticas públicas
deficientes en cuanto a los derechos
sexuales y reproductivos en colombia
donde la interrupción voluntaria del
embarazo es legal sólo en tres causales
91 organizaciones sociales e
interpusieron este mes una demanda ante
la corte constitucional y hoy estamos
frente a la corte constitucional
exigiendo
1 la despenalización y quitar el delito
de aborto del código penal y 2 seguir
brindando garantías a las mujeres para
que podamos ejercer nuestro derecho al
aborto libre desde méxico hasta
argentina el aborto en la mayoría de
países latinoamericanos es legal bajo un
sistema de supuestos si representa un
riesgo para la vida o salud mental de la
madre o si es producto de una violación
unas excepciones insuficientes que
llevan a que las mujeres y niñas lleven
a cabo abortos clandestinos que se
estima que causan la muerte de entre
5.000 y 10.000 mujeres cada año pese a
la falta de registros oficiales los
ramos de la deshonra están hechos con
perejil y otras hierbas que se usan para
abortar en la clandestinidad miles de
mujeres arriesgan sus vidas por la
imposibilidad de acceder a un aborto
seguro diputados y senadores es hora de
cambiar esa realidad el kobe 19 agravó
los problemas de salud reproductiva en
la región y estímulo por ende el aborto
inseguro según naciones unidas 18
millones de latinoamericanas quedaron
sin acceso a métodos anticonceptivos
durante la pandemia
de esta manera llegamos al final del
informativo en france 24 continúan con
nosotros la noche para todos religiones
[Música]
en un instante economía